Okay, I think we can start. Good afternoon, everybody.
My name is Kamil Krance. I'm a professor of hemato-oncology at the Institute
of Cancer Research in London, and I'll be chairing this session today.
Unfortunately, Dr. Altucci couldn't make it.
She was supposed to chair this session, but she got fever.
She's really apologetic for not being with us here.
So it's a great pleasure to welcome you to the session of Epitranscriptome in
Cancer. The epitranscriptome, the field of RNA modifications, has
emerged over the last few years as a highly promising area in research,
offering opportunities for therapeutic intervention both in solid tumors and
hematological malignancies. To date, over 170
distinct RNA modifications have been identified, affecting multiple
RNA species, including mRNA, tRNA, rRNA, and various
other ones.
However, the biological significance or biological functions of many of these
modifications remain really poorly understood, highlighting
the major challenge and an exciting opportunity.
Typically, RNA modifications are installed by writers, removed by
erasers, and
they are kind of functionally read out by proteins that we call readers.
And the paradigmatic RNA modification, which we call M6A,
which I'll be talking about later,
has already shown immense therapeutic promise, but we still need
to fully understand it. So
M6A writers, readers, and erasers are frequently
upregulated or dysregulated in many cancers, and
the field has already demonstrated that the writers of
methylthree methylases, for example, of M6A,
their inhibitors are already in clinical trials, and the early data
are relatively promising. So we hope that this session will spark
some nice discussion and new collaborators.
And
today we have two speakers, myself and Chu-An Hsueh,
who is a world leader expert in RNA
modifications. So, I will just start by
my own talk, followed by Chu-An.
I'm very grateful to the organizers for inviting us both to
speak here. As I mentioned, my name is Kamil Krance.
I'm based in Institute of Cancer Research in London, and today I'll talk to you
about the functional significance of RNA modifications, focusing on
M6A in blood malignancies.
Acute myeloid leukemia is an aggressive
clonal disease of stem and progenitor cells, which acquire
diverse mutations to generate leukemic stem cells, which fuel leukemia.
Currently available chemotherapies damage normal hematopoiesis,
and they fail to eradicate leukemic stem cells.
Eventually, they cause relapses with severe
consequences to the patients. So my lab, like many other labs
in the world, are trying to address unmet clinical need for non-toxic
cancer stem cell selective treatments, and we hope to pioneer
curative therapies against novel targets we and others have
identified to eradicate leukemic or cancer stem cells in
blood malignancies, including AML.
So it is broadly known that the
strict regulation of gene expression is essential for hematopoietic integrity.
The proper transcription is required for stem cell
maintenance and hematopoietic homeostasis.
However, it has been ignored for many years that multiple RNA species
could undergo chemical modifications, which we refer to as
the epitranscriptome. And the significance of many RNA modifications
in normal and malignant hematopoiesis are really still poorly understood,
obviously giving us the opportunity for brand-new discovery with the potential for
therapeutic development. This is the RNA as we all
know it. It has a coding region flanked by five prime and three
prime UTR. It starts with a cap, finishes with a polytail.
What we do know now, and this is just a very basic schematic, that almost
every part of RNA could
undergo chemical modifications.
My lab has specifically focused on M6A, but also terminal
uridyl transferase
uridylation of the polytail, and for the purpose of this talk, I will fully
focus on M6A.
So M6A is the most abundant internal RNA modification,
which is installed by the enzymes called writers and removed by
erasers. And as we discussed, there are many small molecules now
generated against the writers and erasers, and they seem to have
good therapeutic potential. Some of them are being considered for clinical
trials.
And the M6A is executed by proteins called
readers, which drive RNA decay, translation, or
splicing.
We have specifically focused on three cytosolic readers,
YTHDF2, which promotes RNA decay, and
YTHDF1 and 3 that drive protein translation,
although there's some evidence indicating that
they also might work together to promote RNA decay.
So in my lab we have asked what is the functional significance of
YTHDFs in AML and normal hematopoiesis?
So we found that YTHDF1, 2, and 3 are consistently
overexpressed in acute myeloid leukemia in different subgenetic subtypes
shown here, and YTHDF2 and 3 expression
correlates with the leukemic stem cell activity.
So we have performed genetic dissection of YTHDFs, and I'll show you
some published data and then unpublished data demonstrating this.
To start with, we have focused on YTHDF2 because it's overexpressed quite
consistently
in all leukemias that we have
tested.
Here is the western blot showing that it's consistently overexpressed in acute
myeloid leukemia from typically MLL, AF9, and
P53 mutations.So we asked what
happens if you inhibit or rather knock out
YTHDF2 in human and mouse models? So this is exactly
what we did. It's all published. So I'll just go very quickly through this.
We generated a YTHDF2 knockout mouse, and we took
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells, transformed them with naturally
occurring
oncogenes, serially replated them, and then transplanted them to mice,
which form leukemia. So even in this in vitro data, you can see in
colony formation assay, which we call CFC, that serial replating
of those YTHDF2 deficient cells
ablates their ability to form leukemic colonies in vitro,
indicating that YTHDF2 deficient cells fail to undergo efficient
transformation regardless which oncogene you use.
And then we transplanted equal numbers of these cells,
and here I'm showing, for example, cells that are transformed with c-Myc and
HOXA9, very powerful oncogenes overexpressed in
40% of AML. We can see that the
YTHDF2 deficient cells really didn't engraft
very well, and YTHDF2 deletion very
significantly extended latency of AML.
And to test the clinical significance of this, we knocked
down YTHDF2 in many-- now I'm showing
three
primary patient samples, and we can see that the knockdown of YTHDF2, not
even full knockdown, almost completely ablated the ability of AML
cells to form colonies in culture, indicating that it's critical for human
AML.
So to understand the molecular mechanisms underlying this, we did RNA sequencing or
gene expression analysis combined with M6A sequencing,
and we really found that the genes that are significantly upregulated
upon YTHDF loss are enriched in M6A
occupancy. So this is exactly what's expected and published by others.
Then we performed the SLAMseq to determine the global RNA
stability assay, and we can see here that the M6A modified
transcripts have
increased stability upon YTHDF deletion.
But performing ribosomal profiling,
we found that the translational efficiency is not affected upon
YTHDF2 deletion, apart from YTHDF2 itself.
So we think that inhibition of YTHDF2 essentially stabilizes
multiple M6A modified transcripts.
And one of those transcripts that we focused on was TNF receptor 2, which is highly
methylated in human and mouse. And to cut the story short,
we essentially demonstrated the way YTHDF2 binds the TNF receptor 2
transcript and results in its degradation.
And if you inhibit or delete, in this case, a TNF receptor 2, which is a
cell surface molecule, then it gets surely
upregulated quite significantly in leukemic cells on the cell
surface. And then we treated those YTHDF knockout cells
with TNF, and we found that they undergo very exuberant
apoptosis. So increased expression of TNF receptor 2
upon YTHDF2 loss could be sensitizing AML cells to
TNF and could form one of the mechanistic insights
why we lose
very quickly YTHDF2 deficient leukemic cells.
So we think that YTHDF2 itself is a therapeutic target in
acute myeloid leukemia, where it allows eradication, a partial at
least eradication of leukemic stem cells.
But if it was to be a therapeutic target, then the question is: what is the impact
on normal hematopoiesis? So that's another question we asked, and
these data are also published, but essentially we
generated a floxed mouse, which is
inducibly deleted by MxCre. So we took these mice, we acutely
deleted YTHDF2 and followed the hematopoiesis in
different lineages. You can see here.
The short story is that acute deletion of
YTHDF2 did not compromise survival or long-term steady state
hematopoiesis. These mice survived beyond
one year and had absolutely no phenotype, apart from one that we noticed.
Here
I'm just showing you very briefly,
expansion of hematopoietic stem cells in multiple different
progenitors. I'm not going into the details. It's published.
We found that it's because of upregulation of pro-inflammatory
signaling going on, but it's not malignant and doesn't really
derail normal hematopoiesis in steady state, but we can discuss it
after the session.
So we think that YTHDF2 is a therapeutic target in acute
myeloid leukemia and
ablating AML, but in a way, really actually at
least in part boosting the hematopoietic stem cell expansion and normal
hematopoiesis, at least in the short term.
So another target that we focused on here is YTHDF3.
It's overexpressed in
different AML subsets, but also its expression correlates with leukemic stem
cell activity.
So in this case, we collaborated with Jacob Hanna in Weizmann Institute, who
gave us the YTHDF3 knockout mice, and we crossed them to
mice which are MLL-AF9
transgenic mice in which the oncogene is induced by doxycycline.
So we performed in vitro and in vivo experiments shown here, and we can see
that deletion of YTHDF3 very significantly
induced apoptosis in leukemic cells.
And when you take these cells and transplant them to mice, essentially what we
can see is that there's a nice delay in leukemogenesis upon deletion of
YTHDF3. So, then we
tested yet another model just to make sure that this
applies to different ones. And in this case, we took
c-Kit positive stem and progenitor cells.
We transformed them with c-Myc and HOXA9 oncogenes,
performed colony assays, and then this was followed by primary
transplantation into recipients.
And we can see that deletion of YTHDF3 ablates the ability
of cells to form leukemic colonies, and upon transplantation, it
delays leukemogenesis in
mice.I don't want to
go into technical details, but we wanted to enumerate leukemic stem
cells, and the gold standard way to do it is to perform limiting
transplantation assays, limiting dilution assays, where you take
different doses of bone marrow cells from YTHDF
control and knockout cells,
and
we
can estimate, using Poisson statistics, the
frequency of leukemic stem cells.
And in this case, we can see that the frequency of leukemic stem
cells in a YTHDF3 deletion is
hugely decreased. So YTHDF3 is essential for leukemic stem
cell maintenance.
Then we knocked down the YTHDF3 expression
in THP-1 cells, with MLL-AF9 translocation.
And sure enough, we found that this induces very significant
apoptosis in THP-1 cells, but various other leukemic human cell
lines, and it slows down the growth.
Then we performed a PDX model using this THP-1 cell line, and we can see
that YTHDF3 knockdown almost completely
ablated the ability here to engraft into the liver, which typically
is very well engrafted
with this particular cell line, and this resulted in an
increase of latency of the
leukemogenesis. So YTHDF3 is essential for human AML cell
engraftment.
And then I talked to clinicians, and we asked, "What is the biggest
problem in our clinic in Royal Marsden Hospital?" And they told me, "P53
mutation." If you have P53 mutation in AML, it's one
of the most poor
prognostic
factor in AML. It's mutated in AML, and it's an
ultra-high risk, therapy-resistant disease.
P53 mutations cause really aggressive, very progressive
disease. So these are very preliminary data.
I'm showing you two patient samples here, but we have done far much more
over the last few days, in fact, and we can see that the knockdown of
YTHDF3 in primary patient samples
decreased the clonogenic capacity
of these colonies in culture. We are now planning to do PDX
models. These are very preliminary data, but I thought I'll share them with you
here.
And then we asked the question, well, what happens really is that
it's very unlikely that one therapy, monotherapy, will treat
AML patients. We probably need to combine them with different
agents. So here we ask the question, what happens if you delete
YTHDF3 and combine it with the current standard
of care, which is Ara-C? And we can see that essentially
YTHDF3 deletion sensitized
to
Ara-C. We can see that the IC50-- Sorry, I switched
those numbers here. I was too keen to show you these data, and I generated this
slide when I was jet lagged. But essentially what I'm trying to say is that IC50
for Ara-C is decreased upon
YTHDF3 deletion. So essentially, an activation of
YTHDF3 sensitizes AML cells to standard of care.
And then we asked the question, is this applicable to any other diseases?
And I don't want to go into major details, but essentially, we focused on multiple
myeloma, which is an incurable disease of plasma cells.
And we took multiple different cell lines in collaboration with our
clinicians in ICR, Charlotte Poland, in this case.
They are diverse
samples of cell lines derived from patients with different
mutations. And what we can see is that regardless of the mutation, regardless of
the cell line, if you knock down YTHDF3,
this compromises multiple
myeloma cell survival.
So then we wanted to understand the impact of YTHDF3 deletion on normal
hematopoiesis, and to cut the long story short, we didn't observe any phenotypes.
We saw no toxicity in normal blood.
We can see that the B cell, T cell, and myeloid
compartment develops very well in the spleen and the bone marrow,
and hematopoietic stem cells are unaffected.
Even we can see expansion of multipotent progenitors.
And then we transplanted hematopoietic stem cells from
YTHDF3 knockout mouse
in primary and secondary recipients.
So in other words, we performed a serial transplantation.
We can see that upon primary transplant, we observed no
differences in the long term. However, if we
sort hematopoietic stem cells from primary recipients and put into secondary
recipients, we begin to see some subtle defects upon YTHDF3
deletion, but that's a very, very long and
stressful experiment. So essentially when you harvest the bone marrow from these
mice, we can still see decent numbers of hematopoietic stem cells in the
recipient mice, really indicating that YTHDF3 is not essential
for hematopoietic stem cell maintenance.
So then we wanted to understand molecular biology behind it.
These are preliminary data we are trying to understand, but essentially we
performed RNA-seq and combined it with m6A sequencing we've done
before. And we found that really loss of YTHDF3 does not
alter, in our case, in leukemic cells,
global levels of m6A modified transcripts.
Then we performed Ribo-seq. I mean, Joan published in the past that
YTHDF3 is controlling protein synthesis.
We are trying to
kind of replicate this, and we are seeing it in leukemic cells in a
slightly subtle way. We have done Ribo-seq here.
We can see that
YTHDF3 deletion subtly compromises translation efficiency of
m6A modified transcripts. These are preliminary data.
We need to improve this, but we did a completely different approach
now. We performed transcriptome in these cells and
together with proteome that we have done recently, and we combined them
in different clusters, and we have focused on two clusters, the bottom ones
hereWhere transcripts are either unaffected or going down
upon YTHDF3 deletion, but the proteins are
really down-regulated. And then when we performed a GO analysis, a very
other functional analysis, what we are seeing is cytosolic translation,
mitochondrial translation, ribosomal biogenesis.
So it was quite striking. We still don't understand exactly what's going on,
whether it's translation, ribosomal assembly, biogenesis, we don't
know. But basically what we are seeing is that upon YTHDF3
deletion, a lot of M6A transcripts and
proteins are down-regulated, and these are the ones that are
normally up-regulated in leukemic stem cells.
So then we asked the question: what happens in multiple myeloma?
I don't have time to go into the details, but we performed essentially very similar
clustering where we found a lot of proteins being down-regulated.
And the GO analysis, again, indicated in a completely different disease,
cytosolic translation, cytoplasmic translation initiation,
mRNA processing. And you can see here,
diverse proteins being down-regulated
upon YTHDF3 knockdown here
in myeloma cells, and they all belong to RNA processing
pathway.
So then we asked, well, can we actually a little bit more functionally validate it?
It's so brand new to me and our lab, so we are learning all these technologies.
We collaborated with various people at ICR who know better how to do it.
And essentially what we found is that both in mouse AML cells and
human AML cells with the knockdown or knockout of YTHDF3, we can see
a polysome defect here. Here, those
peaks I'm showing you here, they are heavy polysomes, and we can see that they
fail to assemble efficiently or translate
into proteins. So then we kind of fractionated those
polysomes. Again, these are preliminary data, but we can see that those large
polysomes that seem to be defected
in the absence of YTHDF3, they fail to
efficiently translate M6A transcripts, at least the
selected transcripts I'm showing you here.
There's much more to be done to prove
it better.
So we think that YTHDF3 inactivation compromises AML
by affecting ribosomal function
or ribosomal assembly or biogenesis.
We are still trying to find a distinction here, but whatever you do,
or whatever happens, YTHDF3 inhibition or
inactivation compromises leukemia but has no impact on
normal hematopoiesis.
Then we ask the question: well, what happens if you inhibit
YTHDF3 and YTHDF1? YTHDF1 is also shown
to promote protein translation, so we generated the double
mutant cells.
Here I'm just showing you that YTHDF1 is required for leukemogenesis
upon MLL transformation just the same way that YTHDF3 is
required. But then we generated double knockout mice where they
lack YTHDF1 and 3, and we can clearly see that there's very
little going on in these--
sorry. What I'm trying to say is that if you knock out YTHDF1,
3, or both, there's no synergistic effect
here. For instance, here we can see a Kaplan-Meier curve
with mice injected with wild type cells.
They really die from leukemia pretty fast.
But if you delete YTHDF1, 3, or both, there's somehow
no exacerbation of this anti-leukemic effect.
Importantly, we looked at normal hematopoiesis in these mice, and
to cut the long story short, there was a pretty normal
multi-lineage hematopoiesis. We even noticed that hematopoietic stem
cells were in fact expanded upon mutation of 1 and 3
paralogs. Then we performed a transplantation assay, and
again, what we found is that combined
deletion of YTHDF1 and 3 does not affect the ability of
hematopoietic stem cells to reconstitute multi-lineage hematopoiesis.
So we think that YTHDF3 in this case is a good therapeutic target,
but inhibition of both of them, if we had a drug, for example, that inhibits both
of them, will not have any toxicity against
normal hematopoiesis.
So then we ask the question: well, what happens if you
delete YTHDF1 and 3? They are both very highly overexpressed in
leukemia.
So here what we found is that if you knock down YTHDF1
or 2, you obviously have down-regulation of
growth. But if you knock down both of them, there's a very severe
defect and very
strong pro-apoptotic effect upon knockdown of
YTHDF1 and 2.
So we generated mice that lack YTHDF1
and 2. Sorry, there are some
labels that are missing here. But what I'm trying to show here is that if you
delete YTHDF1 and 2,
you get almost complete ablation of leukemogenesis in vitro.
And if you manage to grow enough cells and perform
transplantation with them, there's a complete ablation of ability
of these cells to generate leukemia if you delete both
YTHDF1 and 2.
So I showed you that
YTHDF2 recognizes
M6A-modified TNF receptor 2.
When you delete 1 or 2, TNF receptor 2 goes up,
but if you delete YTHDF1 and 2 together, it seems like
there's an additive effect. So perhaps
a loss of YTHDF1 and 2 is sufficient to up-regulate TNF receptor, and
1 and 2 are possibly likely acting together to repress this
locus. In this case, they might have some overlapping functions.
So we think that the deletion of YTHDF1 and 2
has very strong anti-leukemic effect, almost curative.And
the question is: does it affect normal hematopoiesis?
So these are very preliminary data.
We generated wild-type cells, and at the end of all these graphs, you can see
double knockout cells, double knockout mice that lack YTHDF1
and 2 inducibly. And to cut the long story
short, these mice don't develop any severe defects as we kind
of expected.
Some people probably even said that it would be very lethal, but
we didn't notice that.
What we see is that these mice have normal red blood cells, normal
platelets. They have normal multilineage steady-state
hematopoiesis.
And then we looked at hematopoietic stem cells, and
one would have expected they would be gone.
Actually, they are still there, and they are performing quite well.
So the entire hematopoietic hierarchy is
unperturbed upon deletion of YTHDF1 and 2
genetically.
So we think that deletion or inhibition of YTHDF1 and 2
could also function as a good therapeutic target where you ablate
leukemia but preserve normal hematopoiesis.
So are YTHDFs redundant? Can we substitute one
another? I think it's very, very complex and context specific, and
we are not in a position to get into this dispute.
But what we did was to try to replace
YTHDF1 with 2. So essentially what we did
was to knock in YTHDF1
into the locus of YTHDF2 and ask the question, can we at least in
part rescue some phenotypes? And indeed, it was the case, at least in
hematopoiesis, but not necessarily in leukemia.
So if you remember from the beginning of my talk, I showed that
YTHDF2 knockout expanded hematopoietic stem cells.
And what I'm showing here is that those stem cells,
with this knock-in model are no longer expanded, and the multiple
progenitor cells are also not expanded, indicating that
the YTHDF1 can substitute for
YTHDF2 functionally, at least in normal hematopoiesis.
I don't have the leukemia data to show here, but in leukemia, we didn't see
that.
So is targeting the YTHDF domain
sufficient to inactivate YTHDF2?
How do we actually
go about it? How do we inhibit YTHDF2 therapeutically?
So as you can see here, the C terminus of
YTHDF2 and other YTHDFs have three conserved
tryptophans, and every single each of them is required for M6A
binding. So we ask the question, what happens if you mutagenize one of them, the
final one? And here is the structure of a wild-type YTHDF2
embracing the M6A. And if you delete or substitute
one tryptophan into alanine, the M6A binding
is hugely decreased. So we made that mouse by CRISPR-Cas9
together with Donald O'Carroll in Edinburgh, and we asked the question:
what happens to normal and malignant hematopoiesis?
What is the impact of this genetic disruption of this
YTHDF2 M6A binding in normal and malignant hematopoiesis?
So to cut a long story short, we generated wild-type mice, knockout
mice for YTHDF2, and those that we call WA, which is the
tryptophan to alanine substitution.
And essentially what we found is that these mice are born.
They are
pretty happy, but the WA mutation does
recapitulate the stem cell expansion upon knockout.
And importantly, in various other
compartments, we see the same. For example, the WA
mutation still displays the expansion of multipotent
progenitors that we do also observed in the knockout mice.
So that indicates that YTHDF2 function in normal hematopoiesis is
dependent on M6A binding.
Then we crossed these WA mice to the MLL-translocated mice that are
leukemic, and we performed colony assays.
And you can clearly see just in vitro data that if you just
introduce that one point mutation, you ablate the ability
of leukemic cells or pre-leukemic cells to form leukemia.
They basically fail to proliferate, and they die.
So we think that targeting the YTHDF domain is
sufficient to inactivate YTHDF function.
The binding is really critical, and the disruption of this binding
compromises AML and results in hematopoietic stem cell expansion.
So like many other people in the world, we have also tried to make
our own inhibitor. Sadly, I can't show you the structure because of the IP
reason, but we've got a small molecule inhibitor that essentially,
I'm not claiming it's selective for YTHDF2 at all.
It's an improved version of the tool compound,
but it does displace the M6A from aromatic
pocket. Its IC50 is only 11
micromolar, so it's very much compound in optimization.
But what we can see is that if you titrate the levels of this compound,
it does slow down the proliferation of leukemic cells
and results in the massive apoptosis, which partially
is rescued by YTHDF knockdown. I'm not showing this data
here. And we can see, for example, here, the colony
formation assay. If you plate leukemic cells into the
methylcellulose and you treat them with
diverse doses of this compound, it completely ablates the ability to
form leukemic colonies in culture.
So we think that therapeutic targeting of YTHDFs
will happen. It's a great way forward for
leukemia treatment. They're independent therapeutic targets.
Whichever every single each of them you target, in fact, you get
anti-leukemic effect. And I think that they can
be safely inactivated in combination.
M6A binding pocket is essential for their function.And the drug
discovery, sure enough, is ongoing at ICR with my colleagues
possibly present here, and obviously various other
institutions. So I'm really grateful to my
hardworking lab
in London and various collaborators, Donal O'Carroll, who introduced
me to M6A biology, Chris
Schofield, who made small molecule inhibitors, and various
colleagues in Paul Clarke, Gary Newton, and Rob
Van Montfort, who are now working with us to generate small molecule
inhibitors against YTHDF2. And I'm extremely
grateful for the funding, in particular the Cancer Research UK.
Thank you so much for your attention.
So my job is to also moderate this session, so I'm very happy to take questions
before we move on.
Please, if you could use the mic in different rows, that would be great.
Hi, Dr. Krank. It's very nice data and
the presentation. I have one question.
Did you notice in the YTH family, does any
mutations in the patient data?
And the second question, you mentioned that it showed effects
with the ARC therapy, so
I wonder,
I didn't check to see your data clearly.
Did you have any viable data show
this combination will show some resistant
in the future?
Resistance?
Yeah.
We haven't looked. I was too enthusiastic, and I made this slide last night because
my post-doc sent it to me. These are data that were generated a couple of days ago.
We haven't looked into this. We are looking at different combinations.
We are looking at RSC, but we also have done synthetic lethality screen, the
CRISPR screen. We are finding really interesting
targets. But about the resistance, I don't have a clue.
We haven't looked into that. It's a great thing.
We should definitely look into this.
Yeah. Thank you.
And going back to your first question about the mutation in YTHDFs,
there are some mutations that don't seem to have a phenotype.
They are typically, I think, in the N-terminus, the unstructured
part of YTHDFs.
But as far as I can see, there is no association with any
disease that has been looked at so far.
Yeah. Thank you very much.
Good afternoon. Andrea Casazza, Epix Therapeutics.
Fascinating presentation, and I'm triggered about the link
between DF3 and the TP53 mutation.
You nicely disclose a very good correlation with TP53
mutant and the deletion of DF3 or
DF1.
Do you know
whether in TP53 wild type, you have the same
effect? You used the HP1 model, but actually that is
TP53 mutated as well.
It is P53 mutated, I know. Yes,
P53 doesn't really segregate whether they are sensitive or
resistant. Essentially, when I moved to my current institute, I asked the question,
what is the
biggest clinical need in our clinic?
They said P53 mutation and an inversion of
chromosome 3, which doesn't even achieve any
remissions. So we focused on this cohort of
patients, and we are really delighted to see that we can actually ablate the
P53 mutant AML at distant vitro, and we are trying PDX models.
But if you look at various cell lines or patient samples that are
P53 wild type, they respond evenly, equally.
I see.
So P53 doesn't segregate responders and non-responders.
And is DF1 or DF3 more effective
on TP53 mutation?
We definitely looked, and we are looking for much more in detail in
YTHDF3
and
P53. Mutant AML seems to be very
sensitive. For YTHDF2, we haven't done that much yet.
We are planning to do it. We just got funding to do it.
But I can't tell you at this stage
which ones are the responders and which ones are not responders.
We're just collecting a lot of samples to do this work.
Thank you.
Very nice talk. Mike Harris from MLK-
Hi
... from MSK. And I have a ton of questions for you, but I'm just going to do
one. The WA mutant, what's happening in the mechanism?
Is it the same as the loss of DF2 or the WA
mutant?
And what happens with stability of the protein?
And do you have any sense of the sort of-
Yeah, we are really looking into this, but we still see the same
hallmarks that we saw in the knockout.
So we still see upregulation of pro-inflammatory transcripts.
So in our paper in 2021, we published that if you
delete YTHDF2, you get stabilization of the pro-inflammatory
pathways that are M6A modified. We see exactly the same in
the WA mutant. But we haven't gone into
what are the distinct
pathways that are expressed in one or the other. That's something to do.
We are just about to do single-cell sequencing in both and compare them side by
side, but we haven't done it yet.
Okay. And do you have some preliminary idea with the triple knockout
and with the DF inhibitors, they might affect all three
DF's, right? So-
Yes. We haven't done the inhibitors. We will do them very soon.
Triple mutant, it's a very complex genetics, and
we tried, we are still trying. The furthest we have gone
to is double mutant with a het, heterozygous for the other
one, with different combinations, and we didn't see any toxicity.
But we haven't achieved a triple mutant.
We have restructured the way that we perform the breeding at this moment,
soHopefully in a few months' time, I'll tell you, but I can't do it at the
moment. Sorry.
Oh, great.
I get that comment, that question often, and it's a genetic failure.
It's very difficult to obtain triple mutant with different Cre alleles.
Very interesting. Thank you.
Very naive question, but more biological.
What is the effect of TNF receptor 2 in
AML, and which is producing TNF-
Yeah, people-
... more?
Sure. People have been studying TNF receptor 2 in combination with TNF
receptor 1.
If you knock out both of them, I think that
renders resistance to treatment.
I don't know if these data are published or not, but there's definitely a
correlation where TNF receptor 2 is downregulated in
AML.
And then will change the interaction with the neighboring cells in the
environment,
and that this is true for all type of
AML or there is differences between
subtype of AML?
That's a very good question. It's something that one has to explore.
We haven't looked into the detail. I just don't know.
TNF receptor 2 is just one of many that we have found,
and the reviewers also push you to find one.
But I'm absolutely sure there are many other mechanisms through
which YTHDF2 deletion has anti-leukemic effect.
There are many
pro-apoptotic pathways upregulated.
There's a metabolic reprogramming.
There's a switch from
beta oxidation. There's a lot going on in these
cells. So we are only scratching the surface, frankly.
We need to identify the mechanisms underlying this.
So I can't really comment on this cell, whether it happens in
various other AMLs, I just don't know.
Thank you.
Thank you for your talk. It's great.
I'm Xu Jingyang from Memorial Sloan Cancer Center.
So my question is based on your patient cohort about
the P53 mutation and YTHAF. Is it
any differences, dependency, or different contribute
on the survival on the DAFs or other
M6A regulators, like the writers or the other reader,
YTHDC1?
That's a good question. I don't know if there has been-- I'm not aware of a study
where people studied FTO, ALBH5,
different YTHDFs, DAFs, then DCs, and
metal complexes-
Is it possible-
... a systematic way. I don't know.
Is it possible that you can help me to check a little
bit on your AML patient cohort about-
Absolutely
... YTHAF and mutation to see?
I was very keen to show you these data.
They were ready a few days ago in my lab, but then we've got N equals
few. So that's just the beginning of another program we are
embarking on to
take it to clinical translation. We've got a nice translation unit
first in humans, so we are very keen to translate this project.
But
for now, we just focus on P53 mutated patients.
I'm sure that various other patients will benefit.
I just wanted to emphasize P53 because it's the nastiest leukemia that people
get, or AML leukemia that people get.
But I cannot make any further comments at this moment.
We are just starting to do this project.
Thank you. Appreciate it.
Let's talk about it.
Right. We better move on to the next speaker.
Thank you so much for your attention to my talk
and
it's a great pleasure to introduce Chuan He, who is really
a world expert in RNA modifications,
who is a professor and Howard Hughes Investigator at the University of
Chicago at the Department of Chemistry. So Chuan, please go ahead.
Thank you for being here.
Yeah. Thanks, Kamil.
We were asked to extend our talk a little bit because it would be just the two of
us.
I think you've got a good introduction already.
I just want to
further emphasize, we've been working on the
M6A biology. This modifies messenger
RNA, and we identified erasers, and we characterized the writer
complexes. You've got a very good introduction of the
readers, these YTH domain proteins.
The YTH domains sort of evolved to recognize
specifically to M6A, but there are other binding proteins like
IF2BP, et cetera, also binds preferentially to methylated
RNA, and collectively, they really regulate
mRNA stability, translation, cellular localization, and that
have profound impacts.
So I'm just going to actually go back to YTHDF2 a little bit.
I just want to share with you, this is an interesting protein
that binds hundreds, sometimes even more, methylated RNA, and they
really turn over transcripts. If you have a methylated transcripts,
this helps decay hundreds of those, and
sometimes drive cell state transition.
Here's example from a neural stem cell to neurons.
If you delete YTHDF2 or if you get rid of M6A, you actually
have these transcripts remaining.
They're not getting properly decayed, and that sort of impedes cell
state transition. So we had this model years ago that this
is a way to regulate cell state, but
also stress response by coordinating decay
of tens, hundreds of methylated
RNA.So with that, actually
very much like the previous talk, we thought about this and one
area we've been interested in is hematopoiesis.
We ask if we get rid of YTHDF2, what's going on with stem cell versus
self-renewal versus differentiation?
This is in collaboration with Linheng Li's laboratory.
We showed that if we shut down YTHDF2, we really drive
ex vivo hematopoietic stem cell expansion, and you
can also take this to a mouse, and you can clearly see a lot more
HSPCs when you knock out or knock down YTHDF2.
With that result, we started to become very interested in this whole
system. This is a published work in collaboration with my colleague,
Ralph Rosenbaum, who is the chair of our radiation oncology.
And in the patient cohort Ralph been study, he realized for
those that failed or are non-responding
to
radiotherapy, these patients tend to have very high levels of
YTHDF2.
So we decided to take a look into this.
We made a microphage YTHDF2 knockout,
and these mice do not really show much phenotype, interestingly,
until you give them radiation or
PD-L1 treatment, you can see this very dramatic effect,
right?
And if you can
combine this with radiation and
anti-PD-L1, actually, you amplify this effect, and this effect is
dependent on
cytotoxic T cells, CD8 T cells. You clearly
see the reduction of myeloid-derived suppressive cell when you
get rid of YTHDF2, and for that reason, you
amplify the T cells or CD8 T
cells. So this is a sort of an immuno effect as expected.
What's going on? We actually did a little bit of a mechanistic study.
This has been published, so I'm not going to go into too much details, but
you immediately realize when you have
YTHDF2 and irradiation. Now, Y-type with
irradiation, you can see there's a lot of migrating cells trying to
replace the myeloid-derived suppressive cells that's been killed by
perhaps irradiation. But if you knock out YTHDF2, you saw much
less. So the presence of YTHDF2 seems to
promote migration, and knockdown seems to
prevent migration. And we can
also show that in addition to migration, this
YTHDF2 knockout in myeloid-derived suppressive cell also
attenuates this cell's ability to
suppress CD8 T cells. And we can at least
explain from an elevated level or suppressed
level of IL-10. You can see if you knock out YTHDF2, you
take these
myeloid-derived suppressive cells, and they actually have a way to suppress
CD8 T cells.
What's going on? Well,
one thing, obviously, NF-kappa B is activated after
radiation. And one thing we realized when we've gone through
the YTHDF2 ask why this is responsive to radiation.
And we realized there's actually NF-kappa B binding site at the promoter
of YTHDF2. And sure enough, in the Y-type, once we gave
radiation, we seem to see upregulation of YTHDF2, maybe
explain this is the feedback loop.
And of course, we can knock out YTHDF2.
And we propose, and that's gone, we propose
maybe radiation activates the NF-kappa B signaling, and that leads
to binding and transcription upregulation of YTH2,
TF2. This explains the response to radiation.
If we knock out YTHDF2, what happens?
Well, in the regular sort of
radiation in the Y-type, you can see the
expression of genes. The presence of
M6A leads to
lower stability, which makes sense, right?
But if you get rid of YTHDF2, you see the M6A-modified
RNAs gain stability. Remember, this is the decay pathway, right?
Typically, in the Y type, the methylated RNAs are decayed through
YTHDF2. But if you get rid of YTHDF2, they're stabilized,
and that clearly show from the sequencing data, majority of the
transcripts tend to be stabilized.
And many of these are M6A modified, and they're involved in
inflammatory response. And this turns to be negative
regulators of inflammatory response.
So in general, in the Y-type cells, they're
decayed through M6A to accelerate inflammatory
response in this myeloid-derived suppressive cells.
But if you get rid of M6A, their level is elevated
to sort of
limit the response in myeloid-derived suppressive cells.
We can at least find three examples that clearly show
elevated level upon knockout of YTHDF2, and we can
actually use this to rescue to some extent, the knockout
of YTHDF2.
So in bottom line, this irradiation induced NF-kappa B
signaling, we show this NF-kappa B under this context can actually
mediate transcription activation of YTHDF2 and the
presence of YTHDF2 amplify this effect.
And the loss of YTHDF2
weakens the effect. It basically reduces the
suppressive function of
MDSC. This is one mechanism we figured out.
And then lately, we've been working on this system.
We realized they're actually regulating additional, perhaps
surface-exposed proteins play additional roles, not just
these effects, but additional effects involved because YTHDF2
decays hundreds of genes, right? And this positive feedback
governs the migration suppression, but also actually differentiation from
myeloid cells to MDSC and the communication of
MDSC to other cell types that we did not include in this
study.So,
like last talk, we've and others have shown these
YTHDF proteins play critical roles in the entire
tumor microenvironment, not only targeting the myeloid-derived
suppressor cells, but also T cells, regulatory T cells, dendritic cells,
et cetera.
And we've been developing inhibitors.
We had this small inhibitor that targets YTHDF2.
We saw very good efficacy in mouse model in collaboration with Dr.
Cheng Luo. And
lately, we've developed our own molecules as 10 mg per kilogram.
We saw very good efficacy. We're collaborating.
We actually have a better version of this.
We're looking forward to test this in different models.
I want to shift gear a little bit and start to talk about
another set of targets we have not published.
So while we were working on messenger RNA methylation, we realized
the nuclear RNA, particularly these non-coding RNAs on the
chromatin, they can be methylated.
If you delete methyltransferase, you saw this major
chromatin effect.
So the entire
nascent transcription is elevated.
That could be rescued with wild type, but not in active mutants.
So this is methylation-dependent.
If you check chromatin openness, so this is the way you
use DNase I, treat with your chromatin, you make cuts, and then
you get on fluoriform, you can look at fluorescence intensity
as a way to evaluate the accessibility of the
chromatin. And clearly, if you deplete methyltransferase, you have a
much more open chromatin, and this is methylation activity
dependent.
So I've shown this data many times.
For those who have not followed the chromatin regulation, if you perform
sequencing experiment you deplete methyltransferase.
There's 6,000 genes. Their transcription rate increases
pretty much unanimously. And here's another set
of data. If you get rid of methyltransferase, you saw the overall levels of
K4 tri-methyl, K27 acetylation, these increases
consistent with more open chromatin we observed in our imaging
experiments. And if you do ChIP-seq experiments, you saw
the upregulation of K27 acetylation, K4
tri-methylation at these transcription starting sites.
Give you one example. This is the enhancer RNA that has M6A.
And if you knock out methyltransferase, you saw the reduced M6A
level as expected, and that seems to correlate with
increased K27 acetylation and K4 tri-methylation.
Now, if we deliver a CRISPR-directed demethylation
towards that M6A site, we can clearly observe reduced
M6A, elevated the stability of that
enhancer RNA, and increase the transcription
rate and increase K4 tri-methyl, K27 acetylation,
consistent with the idea in mouse embryonic stem cell.
This chromatin M6A suppress transcription
state.
So YTHDC1 apparently is involved.
I apologize.
Yeah, it should be YTHDF1. This is extra.
This one is involved in nuclear regulation, and if you
knock it out, you can see a more open chromatin,
and increase the nascent transcription, just like you get
rid of methyltransferase. And we come up with one mechanism that
the methylation installed by METTL3 could be
recognized by YTHDC1, that mediates decay.
So that essentially suggests that these chromatin-associated RNAs are now as
templates to assemble transcription active complex. All right?
And methylation is a way to regulate these guys, and then the reader
proteins binds, and that can decay this, but also three
dependent work published a year later showing that this
can recruit binding proteins to change local
chromatin state by modify local chromatin or histone
tail modifications. So essentially,
in this sort of
model, you have methyltransferase that install methylation not only to
pre-messenger RNA, but also through chromatin-associated RNA, and the binding
proteins comes in and recognize these marks and
modify nearby chromatin state, and this can be reversible.
Now, let me focus on YTHDC1 as my
next target. This has been studied by many labs.
I showed Michael here as well.
Essentially, what this tells us is that, in addition to
DNA and histone marks, there are these RNA marks that you
view them as a histone tail modification.
They can recruit binding proteins and change nearby chromatin
state. This can be M6A, M5C.
Our next question was, well, if this is the case,
we should think about chromatin regulation in cancer, right?
Specifically for cancer. What kind of
cancer that involve stemness, right?
In addition to leukemia, other signs we saw about
plasticity, the neuroendocrine lineage, right?
The small cell lung cancers, the neuroendocrine prostate cancer, these
are cancer that I call the stemness.
People call it plasticity, right?
Because if you
drive their conversion to neuroendocrine, this is the prostate
cancer example we collaborated with
a group in Shanghai. And as you can see, when you drive the
neuroendocrine lineage, you clearly see more open chromatin
state. Okay? And we ask, well, if that's the case, can we take a look at
what kind of epigenetic factors regulates this?
We use a single-cell sequencing experiment, and then we
unbiasedly rank the epigenetic
regulators that couldIt's open chromatin.
The cancer goes from closed chromatin to open chromatin,
becomes stemness, plasticity cancer. They're very hard to treat.
And one thing jumps out of this among most epigenetic
factors is YTHDC1. This seems to be a determinant, at
least from single-cell data. It helps drive
this stemness.
And we tested again with different small molecule inhibitors with us.
Because this is M6A binding protein, so we used a inhibitor,
I'm going to show in the next slide, specific for YTHDC1.
We used the methyltransferase inhibitor and the demethylase inhibitor, and
ask what can convert the stemness cancer back into the
normal state, right? If it goes back to normal state, it's probably more
responsive to chemotherapy. The stemness state
is much more robust and resistant to treatment.
Among these tested, the YTHDC1 inhibitor gave us
the best result. The other two gave us barely some, but
no comparison to the YTHDC1 inhibitor.
So this is the YTHDC1 inhibitor that been out there for several
years. The paper just got published, but it's on BioRxiv for a
long time or online, and we were able to obtain
this inhibitor and test in our hands. This is another experiment.
You can see it's quite effective in killing
cells with neuroendocrine lineage.
And we also tested in our knockout experiments, when we knock this out,
YTHDC1, we try to rescue, and we can rescue with a wild type,
but barely with a mutant that
showed that
YTH pocket, we also made a mutation of tryptophan to
alanine, and it didn't rescue that well.
Here's a sequencing experiment, the knockout versus wild type.
You can clearly see the dramatic downregulation of gene
expression, and many of these are involved in lineage
plasticity. So this suggests, okay, there chromatin RNA
M6A bound by YTHDC1, and that seems to drive
chromatin activation. It's a transcription activation, right?
Remember in previous story, YTHDC1 is hijacked to
suppress transcription, but here it's activate transcription.
And we
did a sequencing experiment. It turned out it's really where it binds.
When it binds retrotransposon RNA, that's happened in mouse
embryonic stem cells, suppress chromatin state.
But when it binds to promoter RNA, it turns to activate
transcription. We have additional mechanistic studies I'm not going
to show today. But we ask, well, if that's the case,
what type of RNA it really impacts?
And when you perform a sequencing experiment and correlate
with open chromatin state, it tends to be a loo elements.
Here's another set of data just to confirm this.
When you knock down YTHDC1, you have a closed chromatin.
You drive the stemness cancer back into a
regular state, and then you can manipulate this, whatever you
want, and then majority of the
elements accounting for this, it turns to be a loo element at the promoter
sites and sometime at the enhancer sites.
Mechanistically, we performed the proteomics, and we
realized the YTHDC1 interact with the SETD1A and the
YY1. We have experiments to confirm from these co-IP
experiments. And if we knock out YTHDC1,
as you can see, for those sites with both YTHDC1
and M6A and the loo elements, we saw most dramatic downregulation
of transcription. Okay, so consistent with
YTHDC1 binds to M6A at a loo elements as the
main regulatory function, and similarly, I think this is where
we look at the K27 acetylation, and this is a K4
trimethylation.
In collaboration of our clinical collaborators, we tested four
different preclinical models, genetic models, but also
PDX models. And in all cases, when we applied that tool compound,
we saw pretty good tumor control in mouse model, and we also
did the single-cell sequencing experiments, and it turns out YTHDC1
inhibition depletes the cycling population.
Now that population is getting depleted, so it's really targeting
the population that
grows and proliferates. And there's still a lot of work we
need to do, but at this moment, we
know this is affecting the
promoter enhancer looping, at least in our system.
That seems to drive chromatin opening and
gene expression of the stemness
transcripts.
So that's my other unpublished story.
This seems to be
one of the key factors to maintain chromatin state in
lineage plastic, neuroendocrine prostate cancers,
small cell lung cancer, to maintain that stemness.
And we realized the M6A modification on loo
elements are critical. That involves a few chromatin
factors that maintain open chromatin.
And if we inhibit YTHDC1, we collapse transcription
output of these cycling cells, and this seems to be a good strategy
to control these tumors. Still a lot of work remain to be done.
I just want to thank my student postdocs,
and for
the first part was done
with Wenlong Li, and also
Yi Yi and Ken. I want to thank my collaborator, Raph Wassenberg, Marc Bissonnette,
Liangliang Wang, who used to be a postdoc with Raph, and also the
second part, really, Dr. Wei Xue. We did a lot of work, started
with prostate cancer, and then we got into small cell lung cancer.
Become lots of fun. Thank you very much.
Be happy to answer any question.
Thank you, Dr. He. It's a great talk. I have some questions.
The first question is, M6A can
modify the chromatin,
RNA.
Previously, there is one paper mentioned about the R-loop,
can modify the R-loop. Can you compare the car
RNA M6A modified part with the
M6A modified R-loop part? Do they have any difference, or
they are actually the same thing? The second question is,
you mentioned that YTHDF2 can
make the tumor cell sensitive to the IR radiation.
And I
have one question with, since it's sensitive to the IR radiation,
is it possible that it is related with DNA repair, like
homologous recombination? If it is, so
do you have any expectation it is
regulate any other DNA damage markers, like
GAMS2X or ATM or any DNPK
or ADR? And another question is,
you mentioned that the Kaine can regulate the histone
modification.
And in our department, we just have one group who found out that the
PARP inhibitor can
regulate the chromosome
remodeling directly through regulating the DNA damage.
Are you expecting that
YTHDC1 can regulate
the DNA damage through any
chromatin remodeling this complex or something?
Yeah. PARP1 is actually a transcriptional factor itself.
PARP1 is a transcriptional factor. I have another work on PARP1.
So there's a mystery. PARP1 is not just the DNA damage, it's also transcriptional
factor, activates DNA damage. It actually does regulate chromatin state,
so I'm not surprised there.
Yes.
For your second question was...
I can't remember.
The R-loop.
The R-loop part. Yeah. We have not done that much R-loop correlation with M6A.
I won't be surprised, there's a correlation, right?
But,
we just haven't done it. There's several very interesting papers.
On the DNA damage part, yes, there are several studies suggest
YTHDF2 gets into cell nucleus and then,
somehow mediates R-loop, other sense.
We have not done that much work, but
I want to see in our YTHDF2 story, unlike
Camille's lab, who works on leukemia, on tumor cells, we've been
working on the immune cells. And we definitely see effect on T
cells, T-Reg, dendritic cells, regulatory, I
mean, myeloid-derived suppressive cells.
In all cases, the presence of DF2 seems to suppress
immune
response.
And in different cell type seems to be different pathways.
We're still trying to figure out. It looks like through evolution, maybe during
early development, this is the pathway,
to block immune response, allow development, and then tumor hijack it.
It looks like that way. So we've been primarily work on
immune cells. We haven't checked the DNA damage that much.
I won't be surprised in some cancer, YTHDF2 may be get into cell
nucleus and involved in DNA damage repair.
Yeah.
All right?
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Thank you, Chuan, for a very good, very nice talk. Very exciting.
I just have a naive question. I should probably know the answer.
Why does YTHDC1 specifically, but not other readers,
regulate chromatin states? I missed that point.
What's the overlap in interactum between other cytosolic readers and
YTHDC1?
Right. So the other cytosol readers do not get into cell
nucleus, we think.
Okay.
Yeah. Then there's DC1 and DC2, and there might be
other M6A binding proteins, but DC1 seems to be
predominant ones. And it's very interesting, in
mouse ES cell, and if you compare mouse ES cell versus, let's say,
small cell lung cancer, their retrotransposon RNA
and Alu RNAs are all methylated. But somehow in
mouse ES cell, DC1 turns to binds to, the
retrotransposon RNA to suppress chromatin state.
We don't know in cancer cells, PTM or anything that
turned it into the promoter site. And
retrotransposon are still M6A methylated, but the majority of the DC1
seems to bind at the promoter sites, and there it activates
transcription.
Right.
Yeah. And why is the mark that-- We did
unbiased. We were not particularly looking for M6A.
We were just like, "Okay, what kind of epigenetic factors involved in
the stemness regulation?"
Because, to me, it's just the stemness.
And this one ranks at the top.
That's great. Do we have any other questions?
Xue Jing Yang from Michael Carruth's lab.
My question-
Surprised Michael doesn't have a question.
Michael has a great story on DC1, but that's in leukemia.
Yes. So my question is,
for different background of cancer, solid tumor or leukemia,
did you see different
recruitment from DC1 to have different
functions by the-
Right
... chromatin or instability or
other function splicing? So what is
expertise from you on that?
Contact
Yeah, we did not work on leukemia at all because I know Michael's been working on
it. We did not work on that at all, but we do work on another small
RNA. When we work on small RNA, we do see DC1 actually
come to the same site.
But we
did not really work on DC1. We did K562
cells to map our small RNA binding site, and we also
saw DC1 come to bind M6A
promoter, and looks like this activates transcription, but we did not.
Looks like it's a similar type of regulation, but
we don't know. We don't know the consequences. We did not follow.
Thank you. And also, did you also look at the other
M6A regulators also play the role of
modulate the chromatin?
Right. They are,
yeah. They are not as strong as DC1.
DC1, it's stronger.
Yeah.
Is the only 5'
modified M6A that contributes to the
chromatin change or-
It's not 5'. I think it's modified at the promoter RNA,
and then some enhancer RNA. It's not on the messenger
RNA. Some may be on intronic side, but
majority, I think, is promoter RNA.
For these solid tumor, have you ever specifically to
see the stop codon closed by
M6A, which of the reader contributes on
that set of-
No, that's mRNA. Here's a chromatin RNA.
It sounds like an oral exam.
Oh. Thank you.
Yeah.
Yeah, be happy to chat afterwards.
Thanks.
Okay, you go to me to ask a question, that's fine.
Yeah. You have to.
But
I guess the question is, why do you think
causes, and maybe it's related to her questions were, that it goes
from a transcriptional repressor to a transcriptional activator in different
cell types and cell contexts?
Yeah. At beginning, I thought-
Interacting
... methylation would be different, but the methylation's still there.
There's a
change. However,
in solid tumor, it just binds like promoter site.
My guess is a tyrosine phosphorylation or something.
So you think it's a different PTM modification?
I think it's probably a PTM modification.
I think in cancer, it's just somehow modified differently.
I think in cancer, in leukemia, in your case, in solid tumor,
other sense, there's a study from
Wenbo Li,
right, also it's activation, right?
Yeah.
Yeah. And then Yang had a very nice work showing that DC1 is
also a activator. In tumor, it's just an activator.
It's getting hijacked. But if you look at the mouse ES cells,
very clear. You knock it down,
it opens up.
It's PTM. I've not been able to recruit any postdoc to work on the
PTM. Everybody said no.
Okay. Do you have a sense of the dynamics, the condensate aspect
of this?
Yeah, that's another great question.
My guess is that this is also related to the PTM involved
in condensate. We haven't done this.
I think there might be three forms of DC1, some
in condensate, some outside, and those outside may have different
PTM forms. I always think that as a way.
But again, very hard to... We try to develop a method to
map YTHDC1 with the PTM simultaneously,
phosphorylated YTHDC1, where it binds, glucosylated, where it
binds, and it didn't work very well so far.
I think that's really the key.
Okay.
Yeah.
Right. So we've done. No more questions.
I'm very happy to close this session, and thank you so much for being here.
Thank you very much.